without question old town is the oldest
wealthiest and greatest city in westeros
though king's landing is more populous
and arguably more powerful
the city straddles the mouth of the
honeywine river and the bounty of the
entire reach flows beneath its great
stone bridges to ports that are renowned
throughout the world thus we needn't
speak more of them more interesting is
the history of the city for none can say
when it was founded many centuries ago a
few bold maesters sought out the
children of the forest who claimed that
men have lived at the mouth of the honey
wine since the dawn age nonsense
master jelico proved that the city began
as a trading post where ships from
valyria old geese and the summer isles
put in to replenish their provisions and
make repairs
hence the most famous feature of the
city the high tower
raised even before the city walls
as a beacon through the fog covered
waters
originally built of wood and standing a
mere 50 feet above the ancient fortress
of his foundation
it is now a thick stone and rises even
taller than the wall
those born and raised in old town could
tell the time of day by where its shadow
falls
but no maester can tell why even in our
oldest records the island on which it
stands is called battle isle
what battle was fought there
and when
as for the ancient fortress that forms
the tower's base
its walls and interiors are all of solid
black stone with no hints of joins
or mortar and no chisel marks of any
kind
we know it predates the tower itself by
thousands of years
but who built it how
and against what
the maesters who have studied it
declared it to be a valyrian
construction
akin to dragonstone and the black walls
of volantis
as is well known the dragon lords of
valyria could turn stone to liquid with
dragonflame to shape as they wished
didn't one archmaester link the fortress
to the vanished maze makers of laureth
and another maester to the legendary
deep ones who inhabited the iron islands
before the ironborn
oh both marginal opinions without common
support
but of more importance than the origin
of the tower
is the family to which it gave its name
house hightower
the ancient ruling family of old town
known for their prudence and love of
peace and pieces of gold
during the age of heroes when lyman
hightower saw the gardener kings
conquering the reach
he didn't beat them on the battlefield
but in the god's wood
he bound his house to theirs by marriage
and transformed house hightower from
wealthy but relatively minor kings to
the greatest lords of the reach
thanks to lord lymon's foresight
highgarden has always defended old town
allowing the high towers to focus on
higher pursuits such as learning and
trade
on that we agree
when the andals invaded westeros lord
dorian hightower told his wife of 20
years that wars are bad for trade
and to make his point traded her for a
young andel princess
when aegon the conqueror was earning his
name
house hightower traded its loyalty to
the gardeners for his confirmation of
their rights
welcoming him with open arms and open
gates
house hightower bent the knee to aegon
to spare the city from his dragons
i would think such insinuations and
insults beneath even you qyburn
and again mockery of one's betters is
the trade of fools
i wouldn't know
perhaps if i'd studied at the citadel as
long as you grand maester
the citadel is the greatest seat of
learning in the known world
without it and the mace as it trains
westeros would be a land of superstition
and ignorance
like the ignorance that shrouds the
citadel's own birth
even without records we have more than
enough reason to believe that the
citadel began as a court of scholars and
priests
assembled by a second son of house
hightower
when he died his elder brother raised
the citadel so that wise men would
always have a home in westeros
and could continue the inquiries and
debates that had given such joy to his
younger brother
his little brother's pets
as legend has it he called them and so
the maesters have remained only their
masters have changed
now they serve every lord with a castle
for a fee of course
whilst the citadel serves its own
importance
every word you speak merely validates
your own expulsion from our ranks
knowledge is validation enough
i assumed the world's greatest minds
would agree and perhaps they would if
i'd met them old town is a city for old
men and old beliefs
the citadel of old town is the greatest
center of learning in the world
not that it has much competition really
most lords think of books the way they
think of younger sons
useful to have around as long as they
keep to the corners
back when house hightower still ruled
old town as kings a crippled younger son
sought solace in books and those who
wrote them and became the greatest
patron of learning in his day
scholars of all sorts flocked to old
town to debate and write and
debate
after this prince parramore's death his
brother granted land to paramour's pets
as the wise men were called
though now they're known as maesters
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl
the queen had failed to produce a son
for her king so he anointed his daughter
the princess rhaenyra as his heir but
years later the king remarried and his
new wife queen alicent of house
hightower gave him a son
feeble and foolish the old king refused
to change the succession he didn't even
see how his cord had split into two
rival camps of blacks and greens after
the dresses of the princess and the
queen had worn to some torny
[Music]
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
queen alicent
protocol dictated that the bells would
be rung and a raven sent to dragonstone
to summon the air princess rhaenyra for
her coronation but alison had other
plans
once she saw her dead husband's body she
sealed the room and had the servant
thrown into the black cells to ensure
his silence
at the hour of the owl the lord
commander of the kingsguard sir
christian cole summoned the small
council to inform them of the king's
death
sir otto hightower the hand of the king
and father to queen alison demanded that
the succession be settled immediately
the decrepit old men of the small
council were confused the succession was
settled in their minds the old king had
forced the lords of westeros to swear
fealty to princess rhaenyra as his heir
but sir kristen cole rightly pointed out
that a son comes before a daughter
the council argued until dawn when the
master of coin finally stood up and
declared he would have no part of
treason so christian cole wisely opened
his throat with a dagger ending the
debate
none were more surprised to hear of
prince aegon's succession than prince
aegon himself
at first the fool rejected the crown but
his mother pointed out that his sister
rhaenyra would return such loyalty by
taking his head
as the old king's true born son he'd
always be a threat
aegon relented he was crowned in the
dragonpit and his wife and sister helena
became queen his brother aymond flew off
to win over the few great lords who
support aegon didn't already have the
banner of the gold dragon flew over
king's landing in the red keep as aegon
second of his name ascended the iron
throne
when rhaenyra heard of her son's death
she collapsed
she considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
damon
her son would be avenged
whispers slithered through the taverns
and back alleys of flea bottom
two men were found
one was a former gold cloak the other a
rat catcher in the red keep who knew all
its secrets
history remembers them only as blood and
cheese
one night queen helena entered the royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed
without warning
blood and cheese bursting daggers in
hand
they told her that a debt was owed
a son for a son
blood and cheese demanded she choose
which son would be ripped from her
forever
queen helena pleaded with the men to
kill her instead but they refused
weeping
helena named her younger son melo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
or perhaps because the older boy was
king aegon's firstborn son and heir
you hear that little boy she's whispered
to the younger son
your mama wants you dead
then blood struck off the older boy's
head with a single blow
when the guards burst in they found
queen helena still screaming clasping
her dead son's body to her mad with
grief
the blood of their children transformed
a dynastic dispute into a war of
annihilation
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn down the world
either aegon or rhaenyra could live at
the end but not both
one day king's landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul city
damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne for the city was defenseless
eamonn had taken the king's army from
the city
and worse he'd taken his dragon vaga
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small council surrendered the city the
queen mother alicent and the broken
queen helena
but not king aegon
somehow despite his wounds and delirium
he had vanished from the city